i tend to like the
thought experiment of the organism like
humans aren't the organisms
i like the notion of like richard
dawkins and memes
that ideas themselves are the organisms
like that are just using our minds to
evolve
so like we're just like meat receptacles
for ideas to breed and multiply and so
on and
maybe those are the aliens yes so
uh jordan peterson has a line says you
know you think you have ideas but ideas
have you
yeah right good line which and and then
we know about the phenomena of
groupthink
and there's so many things that
constrain us
but i think you can examine all that and
not be
completely owned by the ideas and
completely sucked into groupthink
and part of your responsibility as a as
a human
is to escape that kind of phenomena
which isn't you know it's
you know it's it's one of the creative
tension things again you're constructed
by it
but you can still observe it and you can
think about it and you can make choices
about
to some level how constrained you are by
it
and you know it's useful to do that
and but but they're at the same time
and it could be by doing that that you
know the the the
the group in society you're you're part
of becomes collectively even more
interesting
so you know so the outside observer will
think wow
you know all these lexus running around
with all these really independent ideas
have created something even more
interesting
and uh aggregate so
so i i don't know i'm those are lenses
to look at the situation
but that'll give you some inspiration
but i don't think they're constraints
right you know
you